it's just
you know a normal guy might look at
breasts or or ass or whatever like that
me i look at feet i can't help it it
just happens okay it's it's kind of like
how i can think of homosexuals i don't
think gay people choose to be gay i just
think it's something in them that says
hey i'm attracted to this guy
same thing with feet i can't help it the
first thing i looked at on elle okay
she's wearing cute white gym shoes or
whatever i can tell you details of her
gym shoes but i can't tell you what she
looked like
okay that's just the way my mind works
um you're focused on the feet yeah i
can't help it
just what turns me on i'd be watching
the brady bunch in the early 70s and you
know of course there was marsha jan and
cindy marshall was the hottest one to me
and of course she'd come on and i'd be
looking at these you know thick black
clogs she has i like shoes too
shoes are like lingerie for the feet if
you think of it that way uh but anyway
i'd be staring at her shoes the whole
time you know i mean
i i thought everybody was staring at a
girl's shoes like i didn't think i was
different i just thought oh this is what
i'm looking at is what every guy looks
at and then in about fourth fifth grade
guys are talking like tits and ass and
tits in there like what a tits
that's what you're looking at
oh and i didn't say anything but i was
like that's weird i'm not looking
anywhere near there
you know like guys got obsessed with
breasts in their teen years
yeah what the [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
you know and there's clubs for this and
stuff like that foot fetish clubs well
not as a kid but yeah uh and that
actually started more or less when i
owned the fetish club in new york see
the fetish club in new york was an
interesting thing i was in new york i
was unemployed
and um
i called a lot of hookers to take care
of myself you know and i'd call hookers
uh to do foot stuff i would not [ __ ]
these hookers i would just do foot stuff
with that
anyway
i'm an accountant and i kind of became
the tax accountant to the mid-end
mid-range hookers of new york i did
one girl was at a party there's a
bachelor party she was crying about her
taxes and like taxes you have tax
problems what the [ __ ] here here's my
card call me well the next day she
showed up
with a not a box but a crate of receipts
like this big in my office and she says
okay i need to do my taxes i'm like what
the [ __ ] no i had never done a tax
return i'm a different kind of
accountant i'm a controller
an accountant not a tax accountant but
anyway i sent her away
told her to come back in an hour i went
out and bought turbo tax i learned how
to use it i learned how to do a tax
return right um
and uh when the time came she's like all
right what do i owe you
and i said uh oh i know
500 an hour
so three hours 1500
that seems kind of high
i said you charged 600 an hour for your
services
don't you think i'm worth five
you're saying yeah okay
within a week i had three within a month
i had 20
of all these hookers
doing their taxes okay and it's
interesting because when you're a tax
accountant for these girls they look at
you in a position to trust kind of a
daddy figure almost you know
um so i had all these girls i had all
the women i wanted which was good but
these girls are full of drama
trust me some boyfriend beats him up
whatever the hell it is they call me at
three in the morning looking for
for help and it was the last thing i i
wanted to get out of this thing but
anyway they sent me to this fetish club
to go do the books you know
check it out so as i'm doing the books
of this place i'm like wow these girls
these guys are paying 200 an hour to rub
these girls feet
and
and there's no illegal activity this is
a money machine we are making money so i
ended up buying half of that foot fetish
club uh after doing the books
and owned it for two years and had the i
mean details magazine i could show you
the article on my phone um they wrote an
article about our club and i'm in it and
uh kind of portrays me as a a broadway
joe joe namath kind of character i was
living in europe and i would fly into
new york every two weeks just to check
on my club uh rovin flies in from
overseas his limo out of his limo comes
six girls each three on each arm
you know leading him up to his throne in
the foot worship how all this crazy i
was living like a king you know it was
crazy
so that's how i got into the foot fetish
club and i owned it for two years until
the other owner started recruiting
underage girls oh and also hard drugs
like you know you could have weed you
could have uh
soft drugs and the cops wouldn't bother
you but if you were doing uh ecstasy
which was a ecstasy is the best drug for
a foot fetish party you give somebody a
head of ecstasy they are going to spend
money they're going to feel close to
every girl there because the way the
parties work is you paid to get in
like 50 bucks 60 bucks um and then each
girl there you pay 10 20 for 10 minutes
of foot worship so you can go up to six
girls in an hour
and do 10 minutes with each one it cost
you 120 and you had six girls or you
could spend an hour with one it's up to
you
so that's the way those parties would
work and
they made money bro
we made a lot a lot of money doing that
so uh
yeah that was a lot of fun but anyway
once the hard drugs and the underage
girls started getting involved
uh i said i can't be part of this this
is this is [ __ ] up this is going to
lead to trouble and that's when i got
out
what is it what is it about feet i mean
is it a sexual thing yeah
very much so you're playing with your
toes yeah
getting off on it
the girl doesn't
really perceive it as sex you're just
playing with her feet
usually you're sitting there jerking off
while you're playing with their feet so
you know what i mean that's why these
clubs these parties are a lot of dark
corners in them and you know they're
basically swingers parties without the
swinging
is it a common fetish foot fetish about
11 to the world
11 percent that's what the book says
masters in johnson
so
you know
i feel validated i told you quentin
tarantino is what did it for us okay if
you ever watch his movies there are foot
scenes in every one of me so for anybody
who has a foot fetish who watches his
movies oh it's like a gay person can
tell another gay person trust me a foot
fetish guy can tell another foot fetish
guy um
and it's obvious and of course he's come
out and admitted it since
so he really brought it to the
mainstream and i'd say that 11 is going
to grow to 20
as more people feel comfortable
admitting it and
you know get involved in it yeah a lot
of the girls that work as prostitutes
that i interview will admit will tell me
that they've got
a regular who yeah sure and actually
there's something called the light sex
industry you have the sex industry which
are hookers the light sex industry are
basically [ __ ] blow job girls they
won't [ __ ] you but you could play with
their feet they'll give you a hand job
maybe a [ __ ] or whatever now these
girls lead a different lifestyle than
full service girls
their customers are generally
nicer
less insane
uh less volatile less dangerous
so a lot of girls who wouldn't dream of
hooking
either college girls at nyu or something
like that they will dream of letting
some guy massage their feet for 200 an
hour you know they come by once a week
and they have three different guys who
do it and this is how they do it you
know
so it is not as much of a stigma to the
light sex industry and i would say
dominatricies fall into that too because
you know a dominatrix
it is and it isn't sexual
it's both you know it's kind of a
complex melange of things going on there
but you know i've been naked more times
in front of a dominatrix and i've gotten
off with dominatricies even ones that
say they don't do that you know
they all say they don't do the sexual
[ __ ] because they don't want to come
across as a [ __ ] or whatever plus
dominate i don't like dominatricies
dominant agencies do a lot of footwork
but the problem with the dominatrix is
well they're a dominatrix okay they're
they're attitude they're really
headstrong
you try to tell them they're wrong about
something they go off and you you can
never be right with a dominatrix it
permeates their regular personality it's
not just an act a lot of these girls
they're angry yeah they really just
become unpleasant you know and then you
get into the whole spanking thing which
i'm not into or other violence and
things like tied up at rope and [ __ ]
like that that doesn't do anything for
me um or being a slave um even though my
activities are submissive that you can't
argue there's nothing more submissive
than getting kicked in the balls right
but i'm not a sub i'm not submissive
you're into getting kicked in in the
testicles yeah
right so
that's a submissive activity so it's
foot fetish it's a submissive activity
but that's different than being a sub
with a dumb sub situation
right there you're you're getting a
coffee you're you're picking up our dry
cleaning service service subs they call
them all right not doing that [ __ ] okay
i'm not getting your [ __ ] laundry get
your own [ __ ] laundry i'm paying you
you are my service provider just because
i and that's when you get into the whole
fin dom thing fin dom is weighing
basically financial yeah
domination right where women basically
expect you to turn over your paycheck or
a certain amount of money every week to
service them and they basically give you
nothing you know they boss you around
and [ __ ] now some guys like getting
bossed around and that gets them off so
for them it works but for me unless
you're going to have your foot in my
face i don't want to deal with you
you know you're not going to talk to me
like a [ __ ] slave and you're not
going to
degrade and demeaned me no no no no no
no
so i never really cared for
dominatricity and getting kicked in the
in the nuts is it is
is also a sexual turn on for you yeah
yeah
it is it sounds painful it is but i mean
it goes back to that incident when i was
six years old and i got kicked in the
balls in camp i didn't even know what
the [ __ ] it meant i didn't know i had
balls or what the hell that was who
kicked you in the boss
nine-year-old girl named barbara which
is actually my mother's name but uh she
was from the chippewa's group and i was
in the apache group there was a baseball
field and they both we both wanted it so
we're gonna fight for it so i get out
there get a little popeye you know if
i'm six years old i don't know how to
fight i don't know anything
anyway she just kind of walks up and
kicks me right in the balls i was out
i'm down puking the whole bit
everyone's laughing at me and [ __ ] like
oh and then she stood over me and put
her foot on my face and grounded into
the ground now it wasn't a good day it
was a horrible day
it sucked
but
here i am today getting turned on by
this so i have to say to myself that
something that happened that day
triggered something in my brain that
turned it into a sexual experience that
today leaves me
jerking off over guys getting kicked in
the balls i mean if if you look at the
porn on my phone
okay there's not one tit
not one ass not one [ __ ] in it you will
see lots of feet lots of heels lots of
shoes you know what i'm saying
and if you've ever seen the website
california mean girls that's a great
website to show the kind of ball busting
that i find attractive it's not the
black leather it's not the whips it's um
it's the girl next door doing it
that's what turns me on it's the
everyday girl that you see in the
grocery store kind of finding her in her
inner [ __ ]
and unleashing it on me
and
a lot of girls really enjoy it too they
really get into it um they just find it
empowering or just cool or whatever it
is and
you think they're angry
some of them are that someone just think
it's fun you know
there's plenty of websites that will
show you the different types of genres
of ball busting out there but i like the
girl next door type and
i was dating this girl
about 10 years ago
and a normal girl everything you know
divorced mother of two
38 years old at the time
we went out for about a year
great in bed everything was good with
her introduced her to the ball busting
thing she was a drinker alcohol has been
the downfall of my life even though i
don't drink at all ever
alcohol has destroyed my life more than
anything she was the first alcoholic i
was with and um
i met her at a hotel
and she was already drunk and we started
getting into some play and she just
started wailing on me like way more than
play
acting this was full strength [ __ ] and
she took off her belt so
winging it around her head
wings around my head
splits my head open blood everywhere i
had to call hotel security to get her
out of there
um
yeah because she had some flashbacks to
when she was raped by her grandfather
when she was eight or something like
that
so that's when i realized you got to be
a little bit careful of who you
introduced this fetish to because they
might take it too far
no one's going to get hurt
tell me about your childhood my
childhood
pretty normal grew up on long island
upper middle class
white neighborhood good parents
well i hate my mother now but uh
back then she was okay
it sounds like that
six-year-old event on the baseball field
may have set you in this direction right
more than anything else
yeah well i mean that's how i got
started on the ball busting thing yeah i
i
i don't know how else it could have
happened you know what i mean
how does something like this plant
itself in your mind i can think of no
natural way for it to happen so this
traumatic experience that i had when i
was six somehow transformed itself into
something sexual in my mind and it kind
of has driven my sexuality for the next
40 50
years and you you'll pay the women for
this
sometimes usually sometimes you can get
them to do it for free i've got a nice
little scam all right here's the deal
when i have i generally pay for my sex
all right i outsource my sex life i
don't do you have
regular intercourse and things like that
honestly yeah i do but i don't really
enjoy it
i have two kids you'd rather play with
feet yeah
and i do intercourse to service the
woman it's nothing to do with me
i could fall asleep during it of course
it does nothing for me
um
but uh
what was i saying uh
oh like you know i'd have sex with my
you know my wives and things like that
but honestly
i don't mind not having sex because you
have health risks involved with that
which i don't have you know with doing
foot stuff um and i don't have time for
relationships so i'll pay women to do
what i want anywhere from 40 to 100
right
but i got a secret technique that i
developed uh i also wrote this and sent
it to laurie
it's called the dsw technique here's
what you do
um i put myself dressed up nice short
and time got a clipboard
and welcome to dsw
i picked the girl i walked
opening a line wow those look great on
you
now the reason that's your line is
because girls love shoes
and if you compliment a girl on her
shoes let me tell you something almost
anything you ask for after that you're
going to get a positive response women
people like being validated on their
purchases and women especially with
their shoes take it very personally so
oh yeah those are really nice shoes you
look great in those you try these you
know whatever stop talking to them and
then i say to him hey i'm from dsw
corporate it's all [ __ ] okay i'm
from dsw corporate and we're starting
something called the pampered shopper
program and part of that is you get 5000
dsw points
okay you get a tote bag and you get a
free 15-minute foot massage oh foot
massage okay anybody who has a foot
fetish will be well served to learn and
become skilled at foot massage why
because it gets you close to their feet
right it gets you where you want to be
and it puts them in a good mood trust me
you're getting a foot massage you're in
a good mood and you can easily progress
that to other things so like so you get
a free 15-minute foot massage as part of
the pampered shopper program and i would
sit down and start rubbing their feet
i'd say out of 10 of these girls six of
them i was able to convert into outside
relationships
okay now of course when they learned it
was all [ __ ] that there was no
pampered chopper program but i was just
making this up there was some explaining
to do on some of those situations but
most of them were impressed that i
actually had the balls to do something
like this but one time at dsw all the
dsw people were watching what was going
on they were sitting there in the try on
area you know i got our feet there i'm
rubbing it i'm kissing
like what the [ __ ] is that guy doing
like oh he's from dsw corporate
whoo corporate
yeah he said he's part of some new
marketing program pampered shopper and
talking and i was like oh [ __ ] i'm going
to get caught i'm going to get busted on
this right
engineer an exit out of that pretty
quickly because i saw that coming to an
end but it's a great technique it's one
of my secret techniques that i share
only with special people because when
you don't have any money and you want to
get some action
that's what you do
it's much easier just to pay money and
get what i want
you